j'ai invité doc gynéco pour un dîner de
boulot comme vous le savez voilà c'est
un dîner qu'il devait bien passé et
c'est vite parti en cacahuète je vous le
dis donc doc voilà il était là il était
content d'être avec moi
à aucun moment tu tu es doutais que ça
peut être une caméra cachée puisqu'à un
moment je m'énerve après un mec qui te
tomber un peu bah oui voilà et et ça
part en vrille
j'ai eu peur j'ai vidéo voir c'était
incroyable incroyable
c'est incroyable on va revoir ça tu me
donneras toutes ses impressions après
parce que je sais que vous attendez les
impressions de dresde un déjeuner pour
lui un vrai regard des doc gynéco c'est
parti
[Musique]
allez vous installer aux impératifs et
beau cyrus avoir mon frère je redoute de
voir s'il travaille beaucoup mais bon je
trouve qu'on fait passer des choses en
sont là des idées pour moi un petit peu
avec toi dans tes édition sûr qu'on sait
que la tension demeurait plaisir moi je
vais tenir le truc c'est que il faut que
tu fais plus récurrents je ne veux pas
les missions se disent tu viens pour moi
si tu vois tous les jours lundi je dis
moi je pense que tu vois que le sniper
de l'énergie tu doit rigoler quoi je
dois sortir avec toi tu dois je te jure
mon frère les gens ici que les gens
retrouvent avec haldor sur la vie de ma
mère
on est
les gens utilisent un groupe pour offrir
des cas simon s'est lui dit en fait moi
je suis vraiment mais vraiment super fan
de doc gynéco a bercé toute mon enfance
mon adolescence on te dire maintenant je
te dis sont aussi je mange musique je
vais musique je me suis toujours dis que
tu pourrais poser sur un médecin ce
serait un truc de malade dans instruit
avec que des voix des trucs cool mais je
crois que soutenant des tons porte à sa
complice la chasse aux bugs il m'a
jamais rappelée fiori demanderait mais
rappelez moi j'étais sur un projet de
ouf avec garou le jeune et rapide non
plus donc
touche franck miro à toi hu
ton manger auquel s'associent s'écoule
pas désolé merci à ce que siri lice 10
si j'étais en fait qui doit à la télé
c'est quelque chose qui va vite c'est ça
faire et me fait de venir tous les jours
4 x 4 fois lundi je ne nie pas vendredi
c'est pour toi même toit s'appelle dans
un truc qui toi après les automatismes
c'est ça quand j'ai commencé avec ses
rites
après sa tendance tu connais son humour
ses assure que je reviens juste parce
que je suis en fait ce thème avec ma
cuisine c'est trop une fan recoupent de
toi regarde tu avec doc gynéco a bossé
ensemble bien voir le doc il est trop
fine titre dans son iphone
sa cousine la connais tu veux pas lui
faire
merci hein tu manges un peu où tu veux
on pense qu'elle ou non non c'est juste
pour attirer son attention de lâcher un
peu de lest j'ai senti qu'il avait
achevé d'histoire de combat par exemple
non c'est moi je suis champion de jeu
jouit qui désole
ce que je te dis alors ils disent rigole
pas dans l'émission il s'agirait pas
cherche un mec
à ma gauche c'est comme un pote c'est à
dire ah ils me suivent dans mes délires
c'est un tu ne le rates tu bollery c'est
à dire un truc toi tu vas galerie tu vas
sortir c'est juste je rejoins avec soin
contour et croit floride et quand je
suis à conjuguer j'aime bien servir les
autres j'aime bien ne pas me mettre en
avant tout dans la vie
l'entente vous êtes un condiment tous
les deux parties bref david seul tout
seul mais qui me rappelle de trêve qui
nous sautent porte deux fois puis dès
que ça devient trop chaud donc mais des
papes depuis ce monde et les mouvements
des trolls conduit pas derniers matches
dont 10 enfants de toi tu sais pas mon
frère
ça s'est passé pour moi parce que je
vous ai déranger qu'il a donnée je vous
laisse la serbie et cesser ses tournées
en mer d'être dérangé j'ai voulu faire
le con c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon pas
joué et moi car 70 vous attention au
fond sa gamme gens sont dangereux pour
votre chantier un pont musical rap à 30
buffon retour
[Rires]
vraiment fou de la gueule vous ma gueule
et ça se vend tout le monde il est
gentil avec toi tu es venu nous faire
une faute aux deux photos c'est bon
c'est pas la peine de faire l'euro ça
s'est passé pas l'attendre
tu viens tu passes et les couilles pour
voir si tout est bon quand je chante
beaucoup
la cause
les
je sais qu est ce que j ai à quelqu un
cap et les secours ou kouakou tous les
gros bonnets jeu complet sur l'énergie
j'ai poussé savoir faire peut leur
enlever tout fait vous êtes contents
vous êtes mon sens ça va la télé tout ça
c'est bon ou pas chaud du show au haut
des nichons quelque chose pour iphone et
du show on a une équipe du show tout de
suite c'est rien j'ai poussé
[Musique]
carphi spa c'est un rêve qui est assez
souple et messieurs asseyez vous
monsieur
écoutez moi qu'est ce qui s'est passé le
11 août en direct
d'accord c'est lui nous accueillent
d'accord ok si nous agresser t'es
sérieux souffler touché mais c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon français ça va bien
se passer a réagi nicolas réagi nicolas
bazire
et deux minutes on vous a posé une
question et l'aract un mytho 3 à fait
tort monsieur donc j'étais comme ça vous
allez nous suivre aussi au commissariat
on sait tous et une position un peu le
moyeu d'accord ça va bien se passer
s'arrêtera pas qu'on n'entend pas par
contre comme on rentre dans une voiture
de police
on est obligés de vous palpez bien sûr
pour voir si vous avez rien dangereux
sur vous c'est la procédure c'est pour
toulon paris ok vous levez vous plaît
monsieur d'accord non d'essayer des cdc
communauté moi ouais c'est la procédure
on a des armements passion désarmement
c'est comme ça c'est toi qui tiens tiens
ya par ici question comme ça que ça
questionne par
[Musique]
alex harvey a atteint 92 demain 80
retour avec tous les individus comme
historien pour tout le monde c'est
pareil
paris 10 ans
[Musique]
commissariat soir
pour moi c'est un autre monde ça a
commencé comme en fait c'est sa mito il
est par terre puis l'odeur jeunes qui ne
dure pas de rejet en mer
j'étais en train de déguster senti
passer et vous êtes arrivé au fait c'est
prendre en charge
[Musique]
mais laissez pas vous avez fait
conditionné en même temps c'est chez le
père de mam
c'est une réplique de tony montana
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à maintenant j'y crois pas
en ce moment je me suis dit c'est du sud
où un fils ya 20 ans je suis dit c'est
vrai après je la cherchais un film après
c'est vrai j'ai rien compris si tu
savais
mon frère c'est la réalité la nes super
devant juste faire un petit protocole
qui est habituel est connu ça promet
déjà des caméras qui sont là regardez la
deuxième partie est folle mais c'est
parfaitement la perle a déjà
flo
serrez vous allez vous moi je pense que
tu vois que tu doit rigoler quoi ben moi
je suis vraiment mais vraiment super fan
de jean nicholas pettit si tu vois même
toi sale bête dans un truc à la suze je
reviens juste parce que je suis en phase
avec ma cuisine tu manges un peu où tu
veux pascal où je vois bien la gueule
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qui se passe et
s'arrêtent qui vous avez nous suivre
commissaire mois ralink aux locaux
question
gynéco qui m'a mis mon genre ça suffit
basta soir rappelle le docteur toi
assieds-toi calme toi là mais non une
obligation je prenais la cgn sur ses
enquêtes sur lequel tu à ton tour
assieds toi qu'est-ce qui se passe mais
si je nous comptons une audition bonjour
bonjour ça y est vous vous le menotter à
la hsg moteur mal au coeur mais [ __ ]
s'il vous plaît vous pouvez rester
simplement à côté de ça à côté de
williams en reste là oui je serai ok
très bien je vous remercie monsieur on
va prendre votre déposition
on veut juste savoir ce qui s'est passé
est ce que vous êtes sous l'emprise de
stupéfiants
vous êtes sûr de ce que vous dites
certes ok donc qu'est ce qui s'est passé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
va falloir accélérer parce qu'on va pas
y passer la nuit à moi pas que ça à foot
quoi pardon nous avions rendez vous avec
cyril pour
cyril c'est monsieur hanouna peut-être
oui quelle gare de relations verrai avec
monsieur nenê est un ami intime c'est
quoi ici j'ai une forme de respect pour
lui
vous savez qu'il a des démêlés avec la
justice en ce moment pardon d'accord bon
non quand on est passionné on était sur
le plateau de tournage et on a s'est
rendu dans un restaurant à peine 500
mètres plus loin environ
ouais de là on a commencé à discuter
rigoler un peu parce que là tu tourne
autour du pot nous on s'en fout là tu
vois on n'a pas que ça à faire non
devrait rentrer à cause de vos histoires
d'hommes pseudo stars il y avait deux
personnes sur la table à la table d'à
côté qui nous ont qui vous ont ils nous
ont parfaitement reconnu première fois
qu'on a les jambes brouille avec amina
donc on aimerait bien savoir qui c'est
quoi comment et et bien ils ont
considéré qu'on leur offre et de rester
sur un individu dans un restaurant
parisien selon nos informations ils
seraient actuellement entendues dans les
bureaux de la police judiciaire et
d'écouter ses premières réactions des
habitants les nommeurs drm
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé s'est
passé hyper vite j'étais en train de
dîner avec une copine et là on a brûlé
on gagne pas je me retrouve comme ça
dégoûté alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
réellement dans le nord il ya eu des
tonnes de renversant il ya une bannière
où s'est déroulée cette altercation
cette bagarre vous nous entendez on peut
avoir des précisions sur ce qui s'est
passé ce soir j'ai reconnu quel point de
loin et doc gynéco malgré quatre
restaurants et cantines est quoi mais
est-ce que vous avez une idée de qui a
commencé qui a démarré si c'est plutôt
doc gynéco si c'est plutôt cyril hanouna
sais c'est plutôt les gens qui se
trouvaient avec eux alors et que ce soit
doc gynéco qui portaient les premiers
qui me ok donc maintenant on va écrire
sur tout ça donc qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé réellement couple visiblement
citoyens commencent et c'est tant qu'à
taper c'est ce qu'ils disent et bien
c'est difficile c'est quoi ce set qui a
monté ton qui a tapé est ce que c'est
vous ou est-ce que c'est monsieur
hanouna personnes à taper ouais à
personne at avait donc vous êtes là vous
êtes descendus d'un arbre de noël c'est
simple plus ou moins ah non si c'est pas
monsieur hanouna c'est vous à moins que
ce soit le père noël de tout à l'heure
il ya eu beaucoup de zigzags comme ça
les gens ça bougeait dans tous les sens
mais il ya eu aucune violence précise de
coups portés
les médias disent que c'est vous on le
connaît hanouna il est connu des
services et il l'a pas hélas pas vous
avez trois syllabes aqua et zila pas
quoi nous n'a hélas pas quoi dites là
hélas pas quoi il n'a pas il a
simplement il ya eu c'est tout
simplement des des gestes brusques ou ya
quelqu'un qui l'a poussé il n'est pas
tombé tout seul le gard
non mais tu sais quoi à peine le témoin
faisons la confrontation
genre tu vas mettre le témoin je demande
qu à vous croire de telles attaques et
alors est ce que vous connaissez cette
personne ou pas oui vous vous
reconnaissez personnes massées sur ok
donc on vous écoute monsieur du coût des
examens faits au restaurant ben moi
j'étais tranquille avec un copain je
reconnais à monsieur gynéco lui demande
des conseils et ils m'envoient chili
sous de ma gueule mon pote il n'a pas
apprécié et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ouais merci m'a saisi m'a saisi le bras
ni les claques
[Musique]
vous avez frappé vous reconnaissez ah
non jamais son nom n'a pas eu ce coup il
ya un mec qui est à l'hôpital avec de
co2 paie t il n'y a pas eu de cours faut
arrêter de me prendre pour un con là
[Musique]
haut tu me regarde toi je te parle
il ya eu des bousculades et la personne
a trébuché
ouais c'est ça la glisser sur une peau
de banane ok j'arrête au monsieur peru
là on vient chercher témoin mais un
autre ouais tu fais sortir celui-là tu
me ramènes l'autre non mais pourquoi
mais non mais pourquoi nous mais dit la
vérité
à un moment il faut arrêter on s'est
alors c'est moi je n'ai aucun souci il
est protégé par les médias je le sais il
a déjà eu des démêlés que la justice dit
tout ouais il est régulièrement ici un
abonnement et là son badge d'entrée
méritons de monsieur beaussier si vous
l'aviez en coopération immédiate ce
matin
ben non alors inscrivez la maintenance
qu'est ce qui s'est passé au tout début
vous êtes arrivés ils font quoi qu'est
ce qui se passe je n'y vois que le jeu
s'ils sont énervés jeu sexy jeune est
revenue il est revenu une deuxième fois
à la fin mais non jean ba avec et
de nos services ont volé par alexandru
on voulait parler dit il s'est installé
au sommet qui a tapé mais à moi j'en ai
ras-le-bol
je pense que c'est lui non il n'ya pas
deux je pense c'est allez sortez tuchan
suis là tout va mal nadine ah bon vous
l'emmenez à l'hosto la balle et vous
maniez hanouna monsieur gynéco tout
c'est que c'est un sale bâtard d'accord
réagissez mais rien ici pensez vous
laisser vous dit que c'est une non dit
que 16e je crois je l ai dit à séville
fc ou encore assez bon qu'est ce qui est
beau jeune homme honnête à la chaise
pourquoi pardon
[Musique]
attendu tes chaussures ouais ok ce qui
s'est passé national vous savez quoi je
vais être très clair je vous aime pas
moi non mais c'est pas si sûr du mépris
ou non mais bon moi je vous aime pas il
vous protège la vo de copains
les deux rôles où ils sont nuls et des
deux relou je sais pas ce que c'est des
rouleaux monsieur hanouna menace il est
basé à quoi il est comme ça que je vous
demande qui a tapé
[Musique]
c'est lui c'est lui qui la pousse à oui
bah vous dit rien
il ya donc c'est un parent du coup voilà
c est ce que vous êtes
l'emprise de stupéfiants à l'heure
actuelle non non juste non non mais vous
à vous savez qu'il ya eu de nouvelles
vous savez qu'il ya un désir vous avez
dû aux côtés - op à l'epad regarde c'est
une histoire nous faut pour rien non
mais sérieux monsieur gynéco qui c'est
qui a tapé
je me suis pas rendu compte mais avance
non mais vous vous rendez vous pas
inquiet mais vous avez un problème de
langage ou quoi là c'est lui qui lui a
cessé pour nous ok
donc c'est vous oui monsieur gynéco vous
allez être déféré au parquet demain
matin en promotionnant vivre ses amis au
coffre vous verrez ce que je peux faire
de plus les clés pour monsieur nous
n'allons des mélodies c'est moi qui
allait bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]